[Musica]
seconda media in uno dei licei più
prestigiosi e rinomati di roma un
istituto religioso
l'anno era iniziato già con l'ep i primi
alle prime frecciatine i primi insulti a
sfondo razziale da parte di un gruppo di
ragazzi
il culmine però arriva giorno che
tornando in classe mi trovo il banco
completamente ricoperto da insulti molto
molto pesanti molto aggressivi e
disastri che a questo punto ho deciso di
recarmi immediatamente in presidenza per
raccontare l'accaduto alla preside la
preside della scuola nello specifico era
una religiosa nel racconto la sua
reazione è voltarsi verso di me
guardarmi con un'area tra la
condiscendente il bonario e passarmi un
detergente uno straccio
ecco questo gesto riuscì ad offendermi e
mortificarne ancora di più del motivo
per cui mi ero recata in presidenza e
scavi dai fuori dalla presidenza per
andare nella classe del dell'autore del
coraggioso gesto presi un gesto e
iniziai a scrivere freneticamente non so
più non mi ricordo neanche più quante
volte basta in caratteri cubitali sulla
lavagna
iniziai senza sosta basta basta basta
basta mentre scrivevo ho iniziato a
capire che quel basta non era più
riferito al mio aguzzino di turno lo
rivolgevo a me volevo io fermare questa
regolare quasi banale reazione che la
mia diversità provocava nei più
e da quel momento ho cercato di trovare
trovare una strada anche se la mia
situazione in quanto mezzo sangue un
padre bianco la madre nera era
estremamente complessa perché ovviamente
d'impeto come penso chiunque di noi
avrei voluto rispondere a tono agli
insulti
avrei voluto dare partente focaccia ai
miei aggressori non potevo insultarli su
che cosa sul colore il mio padre adorato
allo stesso colore sul paese è il mio
paese
dunque mi trovavo inerme e impotente
anche nella volontà di reazione con il
tempo ho cercato di capire quale può
essere una strada di uscita quale può
essere un punto di contatto di dialogo
per congiungere con queste persone che
non riesco non riesco neanche ad odiarmi
perché l'essere misto una meticcia come
sono ci impedisce anche di odiare colui
che ti attacca perché colui che ti
attacca fa parte di te ed ho capito dopo
tanto tempo dopo tanti incontri su di
letture che gli strumenti li avevo gli
strumenti li avevo sempre avuti e avevo
sempre avuto in me perché gli strumenti
principali che io ho usato per iniziare
a cambiare questa situazione sono 1 la
mia grande passione la moda come
strumento di comunicazione e due proprio
inno essere meticcio il meti sasch il
miti sa giova spogliato del suo senso
biologico è rivestito del suo senso
trans disciplinare il mio disagio si
contrappone a un'identità fissa
quell'identità di cui siamo quasi tutti
alla spasmodica ricerca e ci crea
malessere no e cercare quella casella
precisa quella torre di controllo dove
pensiamo di poterci blindare e guardare
il resto del mondo ecco torre di
controllo è di per sé una contraddizione
in termini non ci possiamo blindare
dentro una torre poiché è una struttura
immobile e noi siamo mobili controllo
non appartiene alla natura umana
dunque ho capito che la strada era nella
mia instabilità iniziare ad abbracciare
questo questa identità fragile instabile
questa creolizzazione limiti stage di
arti di linguaggi che sfocia sempre in
un risultato del tutto inaspettato non
sappiamo mai quale sarà la risultante di
questi incontri ma noi siamo sempre il
frutto di un incontro non possiamo
rinchiuderci nella torre a punto della
razza pura di un'etnia pura non esiste
non esiste la verità umana non è quella
dell'assoluto ma quella della relazione
della relazione e del confronto per n
dunque ho capito che questo spazio
questo messaggio che crea uno spazio in
cui c'è disordine caos shock culturale
erano era esattamente il luogo dove
potevo trovare gli elementi per la mia
creatività ed è quello che è successo se
non avesse avuto questo shock culturale
se non fossi ritrovato in questo
disordine questo squilibrio non avrei
neanche potuta iniziare ad esprimermi
attraverso la moda è a partire da quello
ho capito che il meti stage è la nostra
possibilità di creazione di una
personalità instabile fragile in balia
di sé e degli altri e questa questa
possibilità la facilità di creare questa
società
ce l'abbiamo tutti quanti perché tutti
quanti siamo dei meticci culturali non
io perché lo sono geneticamente lo siamo
tutti siamo tutti abbiamo tutti una
personalità un equilibrio perennemente
instabile e grazie al cielo e perché è
il caos è causa e il disordine il
elemento creatore tra i più fecondi
elementi all'universo e questo
riconosciuto l'altro strumento che usato
è la moda la moda oltre il senso
dell'estetica che ovviamente è il primo
impatto la moda la fortuna di comunicare
immediatamente di essere a volte più
incisivo di molte parole un colore una
stampa una forma e arriva immediatamente
vi passa la sua gioia al suo la sua luce
ed è esattamente questo
aprire un dialogo con il mio
interlocutore attraverso le immagini
della moda in questo percorso ho avuto
la fortuna di incontrare tanti mitici
tanti artisti tanti artigiani che hanno
deciso di condividere il mio dna che è
basato sul principio di uno nessuno e
centomila chilometri
uno è il mio territorio l'italia forse
quello che si vede di meno nelle mie
creazioni e pur estremamente importante
è una mera dice molto ferma nessuno 0 km
sono i chilometri più difficile da
percorrere perché la ricerca
introspettiva e la nostra memoria e
quello che sei disposto a cedere di te
stesso per aprirti all'altro 100 mila
sono i chilometri che sono disposta a
fare per incontrare chiunque voglia
condividere questo pensiero chiunque
voglia creare nuove identità su basi
comune basi paritarie quando va viaggio
e incontro popolazioni villaggi donne e
uomini del i paesi in via di sviluppo
del sud dell'equatore
non vado lì con un occhio da eroina o
salvatrice del mondo l'africa il centro
america il sudamerica non ci chiedono di
essere salvati non saremo noi a salvarli
questi paesi hanno in sé tutte le
componenti per rialzarsi da soli noi
siamo lì per cooperare con loro
per dare parte della nostra cultura del
nostro know how e ricevere quello che
loro sono disposti a darci non è un
negozio di caramelle dove scegliere il
più bello la stoffa che mi piace di più
la più attraente
no è uno scambio e uno scambio emotivo è
uno scambio culturale nella visione di
una nuova realtà comune come dicevo una
realtà in cui il meti salsi alla base la
colonizzazione è già in atto e
irreversibile dunque se si pensa che il
termine creolo significa di per sé ciò
che di nuova costituzione significa che
le due parti
le due radici all'origine del discorso
sono disposte a cedere ognuno una parte
di sé per creare ciò che è di nuova
costituzione creolo meticcia una una
realtà che non mi permette nessun
nessuna sorta di equilibrio ma ammetto
ho smesso di cercarlo
ho smesso di soffrire così tanto e di
addomesticare il dolore cercando di
incasellarmi di definire la mia identità
indentità fissa no adesso io puro
l'instabilità necessaria al mio essere
ho iniziato con un racconto e vorrei
finire sempre con un altro racconto c'è
un fiore nel paese molto molto potente
che ha definito paesi continenti di
forti una forza incredibile è di una
bellezza ancora maggiore dei vespasiani
ecco volevo parlarvi di uno di questi
vespasiani si chiama i team è un paese
come uno sconto bene e madre haitiana
la prima repubblica nerà al mondo un
paese ha ottenuto l'indipendenza dalla
l'esercito napoleonico un paese un la
metà di un'isola che ha cambiato il
corso della storia mondiale
tutto qui volevo solo dire che è un
paese magnifico non è un vespasiano
[Applauso]